Okay, so our topic today is that is a transaction.
So if you remember, you take admission anywhere, right?
So at the time of admission, you either have to pay the registration fee,
or you have to pay the token, right?
Or you have to pay the prospectus fees, etc.
Is this part clear?
So in our module, we have that particular option,
like we have set up in this.
So the last thing we covered was that
where will your application number come from?
After the application number, how will you make your stage?
What stage do you want?
After that, your admission sources are set.
Now the point is admission tags.
Okay, you understood the tags too.
The main thing is that now we have to make a transaction with the student
in some or the other use.
Whether it is your prospectus, whether it is your token money,
or whether it is your registration fees.
Because when you take admission, you have to pay some amount
for admission at that time.
Is it okay, Tanvi Baba?
Yes, sir.
So what do we have?
We have a transaction receipt setup.
First of all, we have to do that.
Let me tell you the reason.
Whenever you get a receipt,
it has a number written on it.
Right?
Yes, sir.
So that number is automatically generated from the receipt counter.
So what we do here is we set the receipt number here.
We need one, two.
You have to put a prefix for it.
For example, if this is the University of SDI,
then I have put SDI.
So after SDI, three, four,
whatever the counter update is,
it keeps changing.
So you have to set the receipt number here.
Anything can happen.
Sometimes the client tells the client,
sometimes we make it ourselves by taking their initiation.
And after that, the number starts from one.
Here it is already counter updated,
so it is coming from three.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
After that, we have admission heads.
Now what is your point?
If you want to collect from any student,
then you have to do this.
The collection can be in any random head.
It can be your registration,
your prospectus fees,
one of which is your pocket money.
I will tell you about the concept of pocket money later.
Before that, let's go to the direct test
for registration and prospectus fees.
Registration and prospectus fees.
I have put these two.
These are my two heads.
Now in this head, my transaction will come
and in this head, my transaction can come.
Now the point is,
where will this head's transaction come from?
So you had a stage setup
What we will do is,
if you want to collect
from any head,
from any particular stage,
then you will view that stage.
For example, my lead stage.
If I want my child to pay me money in my lead stage,
then I will view that stage.
After viewing, I will go to transactions.
From here, the transaction will be enabled.
So from here, my transaction will be enabled.
Is it clear?
After the transaction is enabled,
what I will do from here is
add transaction mapping.
Now while adding transaction mapping,
we have all the respective courses.
They all come here.
Which course do you want to do?
Which head do you want the amount in?
You will select that.
For example, I have selected this head.
I have selected your registration.
In registration,
what I am taking from the child is
that I have to take 100 rupees from this.
I have put 100 rupees.
For example, registration P.A.
Now what does the system do?
It shows you that
editable.
So basically what happens is
when you go for registration,
then some children are like this
whose registration is done in 1000 rupees.
Some children are like this whose registration is done in 200 rupees.
Am I right?
It depends on how much
you convince the institute
that we will be able to give this much.
So if you keep this editable,
then while collecting the amount
for registration,
the amount will be editable.
If you keep it fixed,
then it will be fixed there.
For now, let's take this editable.
I have turned on the editable.
Now you will not add each one manually.
You will select one course,
then you select one course, then you select registration,
then you select another course,
then you add the amount.
So what do we have?
We have the option of copy course head.
As soon as you copy the course head,
then what will the system do?
It will add all the other courses.
Is this clear, guys?
Now you have two things.
You can get the amount collected
in a single head at one stage.
But in one stage,
you can also clear the amount in multiple heads.
You can also take prospectus at the same stage.
You can also do that.
You have to take registration at one stage,
you have to take prospectus at one stage.
So what will we do?
We will take registration at one stage and prospectus at the other.
At the end, I have updated this.
So if I refresh it and get it checked,
then the transaction required here
will be on.
This transaction required is on.
Nothing is coming in this case.
Getting my point?
Yes, sir.
Now we have the next stage,
the data requested stage.
So what will we do at the data requested stage?
We will go to the registration.
We have added one head there.
We will add one head here, which is your prospectus.
It depends.
If we are doing this for testing,
we can add anything anywhere.
But the client will tell you which particular head
you have to keep at which stage.
What did I do in this case?
In this case, I kept it only non-editable.
I came,
clicked on update after the last one,
refreshed,
recording is on.
Now I came to the application data image.
This is my specific lead.
Take an example.
This is my lead stage.
My application is at the lead stage.
When I will view it,
then after viewing it, we put a thousand rupees there.
So I can collect
this thousand rupees from here.
I can collect this thousand rupees from here.
You have collected
this thousand rupees
payment mode.
You have collected this thousand rupees.
Which head did you go to?
This is your thousand rupees.
We have added registration.
Clear?
Yes, sir.
I have collected it.
Now I will move it to the next stage.
I have collected
this thousand rupees.
I have collected this thousand rupees.
I have collected this thousand rupees in my transaction.
I have got my counter,
its receipt.
I came down, clicked on next,
clicked on update.
Now what will I do?
I can't go to the next stage,
the approved stage,
until I collect this thousand rupees.
I will collect this thousand rupees from here.
I clicked on save.
Now
I have collected this thousand rupees in my prospectus.
Now I am connected.
Are you understanding
what this is?
Where did this come from?
Yes, sir.
for this.
We have made a stage for this.
We have set the mark here.
Now we have
last but not least,
when we go to the next stage
we have 1100 rupees for collection
which we have set in this.
You are in the last stage of your admission, in the registration stage.
We have set 1100 rupees here in the registration stage.
The identity table is on.
The head is not coming here. Let's make a separate head for this.
Because it is from the old days, so let's keep this.
Registration is done, prospectus is done.
Let's keep the bow shirt.
Let's keep that too.
Let's keep the visit piece.
That kid is visiting, that's why Steve East is giving it to him.
You go to the settings in the settings.
After going to the settings, you open the stage with the same entity.
Then you have the transaction.
What we do in the transaction is that we delete everything.
And we add the new single head that we have just made.
We will keep adding it.
I will go to add mapping.
Select the head and put it in the visit fee of 1100 rupees.
I saved it here.
This amount was added.
I copied it for everyone and added it at the end.
What was my previous stage?
It was my lead stage.
In that lead stage, we collected 1000 rupees.
Which was in our registration.
Then our next stage was our stage with your data request.
On which you collected 1200 rupees.
Am I right?
From there you collected 1200 rupees.
Now my last stage is where we are collecting one more amount from the child.
That amount is yours.
You moved it on the next stage.
You noticed one thing.
We had editable there.
Now I can edit it.
I can pay as much as I want.
In the previous one, we had editable off.
So we couldn't edit there.
If you remember, only this icon was coming.
From here, I collected 11 rupees.
I collected 11 rupees in the visit fee.
Now what is the point?
Understand this thing.
Registration is done.
We collected it in this stage.
I will show you in view transaction.
Collect 1000 rupees.
Then you collected 1200 rupees.
Then you collected 1100 rupees.
Is the transaction part clear?
How to do the setup?
How to make the head?
At which stage will the head be made?
Yes sir.
Is the amount editable clear?
Is the amount editable on?
Is it clear?
Yes sir.
If your editable is enabled.
Then you can go there and edit the amount and collect it.
If your editable is not enabled.
Then you can only collect the amount set.
Now we have one more.
That is your save zero amount transaction.
What happens in save zero amount transaction?
I will tell you a small thing.
Suppose you have turned on is amount editable.
Now whoever is collecting the user payment.
He put zero amount and collected it.
That is wrong.
Zero amount is nothing to collect.
Yes sir.
In that case we will turn on save zero amount transaction.
After that he can save zero amount transaction.
We are bypassing it.
Suppose there is no need to give registration fee to some students.
If there is no need then we cannot define it student wise.
So we have made a structure.
In which case we have turned it on.
If any student wants to take zero amount.
Then he can take zero amount transaction.
Now I will show you a thing.
Let's turn on is editable.
Let's keep it off at zero.
Let's check one lead.
We have turned on is amount editable.
Now let's pick a specific course.
Let's pick a specific course.
This is one of my course.
I have selected it in next stage.
In first stage we are taking full payment.
Because we have not turned on is editable.
I have saved it.
In next stage I went to registration.
Which one was it?
I have filtered it.
I have to check transaction history.
You can see all transaction history from here.
Keep this in mind.
I have opened it.
I have collected 1000 rupees.
In next stage I have turned on is amount editable.
If I pay zero here.
Then system will not allow me to pay zero.
Amount can't be zero.
Please enter a valid amount to proceed.
Did you understand?
Now if I go there.
Is amount editable.
If I enable the save transaction.
I have updated it.
In next stage.
If I zero it.
Then it will allow me to save.
Now I can take zero amount transaction.
Did you understand what is zero amount enable?
We have collected zero.
First it didn't allow me to collect.
Now it is clear guys?
Yes sir.
Understand one thing.
Transaction part is clear.
We have to take registration fees.
You have to take prospectus fees.
You have to collect random xyz amount.
Whatever you pay for registration fee.
Or sometimes you pay prospectus fee.
Registration can be adjusted in that fees.
But the money you give to other heads.
It doesn't get adjusted anywhere.
It goes directly to their account.
Suppose you have one lakh rupees fees.
When you went to get registration or admission.
They said that we need five thousand rupees.
For prospectus.
You gave five thousand rupees.
It will not be less than one lakh.
It is different amount.
Is it clear?
Yes sir.
Because of this.
If we need a head.
Whose amount is less.
It means that you gave a token money.
Suppose I have one lakh rupees fees.
I am getting admission now.
My registration that you have to take.
Or you have to take my prospectus.
It will be different.
But I have an extra amount.
Which will be adjusted in my fees.
So what we do.
Suppose we have a head.
Direct token money.
It is directly selected.
We don't make it.
You saved it.
It is a token money head.
Is it clear?
Now what we will do.
Now we have to take the token money at any stage.
Usually we take it at the end.
Suppose we have to take the token money at the end.
I went to this.
I added one more head.
I put it in this.
Let's make it 10,000 rupees.
Is it clear?
It is clear.
I made it safe.
Now what will happen.
When I collect its fees.
At this particular end.
I went to the data requested.
I collected 0 on the first one.
I collected 1100 on the first one.
Now the point is.
Now I have 11,100 rupees.
Why?
Because our 1100 rupees.
We have already added it.
As a visit fee.
And we added another 10,000 rupees.
As a token money.
Combined what did it make?
11,100 rupees.
It has been adjusted.
It has not been adjusted.
Now we will collect it.
We have collected 11,100 rupees from it.
Now this money.
It has gone in two things.
It has gone in the visit fee.
And in the token money.
Now what is the point.
You gave the money 11,100.
But when the child's admission is approved.
So from its amount.
Assume that it has a fee of 1 lakh rupees.
So the system will automatically adjust 10,000 rupees.
Do you understand?
Let me show you one thing.
Let's make its fee structure.
I have added 1 lakh rupees.
1 lakh rupees is its tuition fee.
I have added it.
Now basically what will happen.
When I approve this child.
Approve.
Whatever number you want to give.
Give the number to that child.
I have put the test for now.
Click on save.
Now the child is being approved.
Now we are adding it to the student list.
Basically what happens.
You don't add the student manually.
You already have the data.
So you are transferring it from one module to another.
My child has been added here.
Now let me show you one thing.
When you go to the student list.
And search for the test student.
When you go to its fee.
When you go to the student list.
We have added 1 lakh rupees fee.
Total fee is 1 lakh rupees.
Yes or no?
Yes sir.
How much should be its payable?
1 lakh rupees should be its payable.
But what did it do.
It gave 10,000 rupees as a token.
So when we approved the child.
And added it to the student list.
The system reduced its 10,000 rupees.
From its net balance.
So now you have to pay it only 90,000.
Are things getting clear?
Is the difference between token money and that getting clear?
Yes sir. It is clear.
So this is how it is understood.
The token money that you have.
It will always be adjusted in its fees.
The rest of your heads.
They get collected directly.
They don't have anything.
That they go somewhere and get adjusted in your fees.
Is that ok guys?
Yes sir.
Perfect. Now tell me.
Is there any doubt in this?
Where did the head get added?
Why do we have to set the receipt counter of the transaction?
After that in stage setup.
What is the meaning of editable?
What is the meaning of save zero transaction in editable?
Is this thing clear?
Yes sir. It is clear.
Yes sir.
I am still repeating things.
Basically what happens is
when you take admission
you have to pay some amount.
To pay the amount you have to have a head as well.
Like when you pay the fee
you have tuition fee, uniform fee,
examination fee.
At the time of admission you have
registration fee, prospectus fee.
These are different heads.
So here we make heads in our admission setup.
In admission heads.
In that also we have token money.
We don't have to add token money separately.
And this is not editable.
From here it is removed and from here it is removed.
Then comes the receipt counter.
Now when your transactions will continue
then you will need some kind of
counter here.
7, 8, 5, 2, 3, 1, whatever you need.
It needs a number.
If you have a receipt then it needs a number.
So here we set the number
in transaction receipt setup.
Is it clear?
Guys?
After that what happens is
we go to our stage setup
and at the stage in which I have to collect
at the amount in which I have to collect
I go to the stage and set it.
Suppose I need something at the first stage
I need another head at the second stage
I need another head at the third stage
I need multiple heads at the same stage
so that is also possible.
Like we did in this, data required
in this one.
If I show you in the registration one
I did it here.
Transaction, after coming to the transaction
I have set two heads together.
For different courses we can do it separately.
Like in this course we are only taking the visit fee
in this course we are taking both.
So what will the system do?
As soon as the child is approved after collecting the payment
your token money will be adjusted
rest of the fees will only be visible to you
that this child had paid the fee.
Is it clear guys?
Yes.
Good.
This was all about here
transaction and token money.